I hope that everybody had a wonderful Thanksgiving weekend and got your Christmas decor all up and start celebrating the rest of the Christmas holiday here.
Okay, we're going to jump right to the questions.
What are your thoughts on ground eat or earthy? We are considering purchasing a ground eat mat for my bed will this interview with running for the running the right programs.
No, so I am very much a fan of doing the ground eat.
The ground eat is very beneficial. I mean some people go, oh, that's just a bunch of food.
But when you really think of it, it makes all the sense in the world because what ground eat is is basically you are an antenna.
You are a human antenna and you are picking up positively charged ions all day long.
So positively charged ions all day long are attaching to your body.
So this is exactly why it's even worse in the winter when you're when the air is dry, you're picking up positively charged ions.
That is why when you rub your feet against the carpet and you touch somebody, you can give them a shock because you're your distributing those positively charged ions to someone who is less positively charged.
They're more have a more negative charge. You've created a more positive charge by rubbing your feet against the ground.
That is that is normal when you go outside and you stand on the ground, the ground has negative electrons.
So you are discharging those positively charged ions and you're balancing with the negative charge of the ground.
So that's the whole idea of ground eat. Well, this phenomena is known in electricity as well. And it's helpful so that you don't get a shock with your appliances when you have a charge going through them to produce electricity.
So back in the 50s, they came up with ground eat your electrical houses, your electrical system in your house.
And that third little thing is your ground that goes back to the breaker box and hopefully is connected to a copper wire that then goes outside and is wrapped around a copper post that is pounded into the ground.
You should have a half inch copper rod that's pounded several feet into the ground so that your electrical system is completely grounded.
So if your electrical system is grounded that you're less have to get a shock with your appliances, it's safer for your electrical system in your house.
Well, it's the same thing with our bodies. So if you can ground yourself since you're standing on a wooden floor, carpeted floor or something like that, you're not getting that doesn't have a negative electron charge.
So you're not grounding yourself. So you can plug in something like this to the wall to the ground of your electrical outlet that will then sense have a copper wire that goes all the way back to the to the breaker box that then goes out to the ground that is pounded in copper.
The tube that's pounded into the ground is in a very real sense discharge your positively charged ions into the ground that way it does work electrically this picture shows what I how I don't want you to put on a
and grounding sheet. So this is how if you don't have a knife, this would be the right way if you're the only person being grounded if you don't have a partner sleeping next to you.
You kind of selfish if you just did this way electric partner ungrounded.
But if you didn't have a partner sleeping next to you, you could put a grow deed sheet on this way if this is a half sheet you put it on this way.
You would be completely grounded all day long you're sleeping on this sheet and it's going back to the breaker box going back to the ground in the ground.
So you're discharging the positively charged ions. I tell people though if you have a knife put it on this way put it sideways. So it's just on the lower half of your bed with the grounding sheet.
Sideway so it's on the lower half of your bed across the whole bed even if you don't have a partner do it that way so that you are getting the ground in benefits of a grounding sheet but typically you don't like this is put on over
the mattress here, but then we would put the fitted sheet over the top of that so it's put underneath your fitted sheet.
But put it on the lower half of your bed across the whole bed.
That way you're not losing your frequencies to the grow deed mat and you're still getting the benefits of grounding.
So a lot of people will use a grounding mat on their chair let's say if they sit there they work from home and they're sitting in a certain chair all the time but they spend a lot of time sitting in the chair.
They'll use a grounding mat on that chair you could do that that way too.
You do get grounded when you pet your animal because your if your animal goes outside if you have a dog or a cat that goes outside because that dog or cat or horse or
pet donkey that you have then is going out standing with all four of his feet or hooves underground discharging any positive charged ions.
He's full of good negative ions and then you pet him and then you discharge your positive ions onto the animal.
Well that's not good for the animal well it's it's it's created completely it are charged because it's balanced out of the dog goes back outside again so you're not hurting the animal.
So that's why animals could be really good for you.
Now if your pet cat never goes outside it's never getting grounded so that's not helpful.
So but if you have an animal that does go outside it's very helpful we spoke about this in the past this is why I think horse therapy is very beneficial.
You take a autistic child and you put them on a horse and they just seem to calm right down but horse is discharging a lot of of negative electrons onto the child and really helping balance the brain waves with the child.
The horse therapy can be beneficial for people that have been emotionally wounded with trauma as well and it does have to do with that negative electron discharge also animals consists when a person is injured mentally either emotionally and that can be beneficial too.
So grouting pads, grouting sheets, grouting chairs, grouting different things like that can be extremely helpful and beneficial.
We do have them for sale at our store who we actually have a ground to be a bundle on sale right now and on sale for quite a while but you could look at that too.
I have colorectal cancer and my tuber is on the outside of my rectum. I've been doing chemo for a year and a half and it's been the same chemo every two weeks and every three been getting this chemo in the beginning results results were good but recently I had scans done and the results showed that the cancer now is spreading again to my lymph node.
And the original tuber has now increased again in size lately it feels like the chemo is hurting the tuber more than helping.
Let's not right there. This is another point that we've talked about in the last few sessions that we've had and that it's good to switch up the therapy.
I know that we have had people that have been on a therapy for a very long time whether it be a natural therapy or a standard ecological therapy like a chemo or like a beautiful therapy with really good results and oncologists doesn't want to change things.
I understand that and it's like okay if things are going well then maybe don't change anything but sometimes the cancer is finding other fuel sources and finding a workaround with something that you're doing and you just need to make changes.
I don't understand why you're a colitis would make a change here or wouldn't be the first one to recommend we got to stop this and change something else because usually they do.
But certainly if what you're doing now the cancer is found to work around around this you need to make some changes either you just completely stop the chemotherapy altogether and we have to weeding you need to contact me because we should have a phone call
and re-look at your natural therapy as well because that should be changed as well if there's a change in your cancer like this.
And or you you talk to your oncologist about changing the chemotherapy, been doing four different chemotherapy drugs there might not be anything from a chemotherapy perspective to change too and maybe that's why your oncologist isn't like we need to change things right away because he doesn't have any other tools in his tool bank.
Well, we have to from a natural perspective make some changes if the cancers found a workaround found another way to grow found another pathway to feed itself that you need to make changes just as simple as that.
The possible chemo can be negatively affecting the tumor.
It's probably not like feeding off the chemo so it's it's supporting the chemo the chemo is supporting the tumor that's probably not it but the if the if the chemo isn't killing it at all then the chemo is just hurting your old immune system and then from a secondary standpoint the chemo is allowing the cancer to grow unabated because your immune system.
The immune system is is becoming neutralized by the chemo so it was me I would make a decision to start the chemo immediately can my body get get immune to the chemo as it does with the supplements or details.
Yeah, exactly so it's not that your body's getting immune to something but your it's it's at the cancers getting smart.
Remember your cancer is your old cells is they're just trying to stay alive so we just we you have to switch things up sometime so.
Schedule a time that we can talk we should do another cheek swab and we should just do a complete new workup for sure.
Next question inflammatory pain has gotten so much worse should I be taking the clear inflamed I'm not taking most of its ingredients so whatever.
This whenever you see something like this inflammatory pain has gotten much worse should I take you know whatever the first you have to ask the question what is the inflammation from so what is the cause of that.
Even if you person let's say they have stage four cancer in the inflammatory pain has gotten so much well still what is the inflammation from is it from the growth of the cancer is it from you know some other infection is it from is the inflammation from a therapy that you're doing to try to cause an inflammatory reaction of the cancer.
Is it from a sensitivity of food sensitivity or some other allergen if the patient doesn't have cancer is it from an allergy or food sensitivity is it from an autoimmune issue is it from you got to figure out what it is so you don't you know I've said whenever you have inflammation you can take.
The things that are in the product clear inflamed which are just a collection of bio flavonoids it's curcumin.
It's a buzz wellia it's a sticky nettle it's resveratrol it's EGC G from great T extract it's you know corseted these are flavonoids that will help decrease inflammation well in all inflammation is bad well no not all inflammation is ready you you want to figure out what the inflammation is from you really have to address that first.
Because you can take you know a bottle of the player in play on the day and if you don't fix with the inflammation is from well it's going to be a losing battle so but if you know what it's from it's you know it you know let's say you have an autoimmune issue you have this inflammation because of a flare up yes you can always be safe by taking the flavonoids to decrease inflammation.
But my husband's hemoglobin is 7.8 right now 7.8 is very low on anybody scale most doctors offices or hospitals will suggest that you get a transfusion or packed red blood cells when you're below 8 they might have a rule below 8 some will never rule I could be below 7.5 or whatever the rule is
but that is very low hemoglobin that is endemia and that is going to make you feel like you have no energy so they are recommending IPT therapy and he needs establish to be 8.0 to get this treatment so their rule is in order to get the IPT you have to have your hemoglobin above 8.0 in order for us to give it to you
because IPT is insulin potentiated chemotherapy it's still chemotherapy even though it's 10% were there about the dose of a normal chemotherapy it's still chemotherapy and it'll still you know do a hand knock on your red blood cell content your hemoglobin code so they have their parameters that they want to stick to.
He said he does not her husband does not want IPT therapy right now so should he still get a blood transfusion if you will be not getting the IPT I my answer but yes I would do that for sure it'll make you feel a lot better you need to get your numbers back up it's you could you let's say okay this person has been doing some therapies that have been from the standards of care perspective that have been knocking down his hemoglobin.
But certainly that's not the only thing that is so have some ademia maybe the cancers gobbled up the iron that's at least a piece of it what's called ademia of chronic disease and getting a transfusion can really help boost the hemoglobin levels up and it can make a person feel a lot better so I would suggest that you go ahead and do.
The transfusion will make you feel a lot better that's all the questions that we had to come in today so let's get to your other questions thank you for recommending Dan DT is a coffee substitute I like it.
Since this tea is derived from Dan Delight is an delivered detox fire it is it's good for you so it's Dan Delight in root and it's a roasted chickery in there and it's good isn't it it's actually a good coffee substitute.
That's actually really good for you too so it's a healthy tea that that's a great coffee substitute everybody in the office uses it on a fairly regular basis so it's a great thing to take.
It's called Dan D blend so if anybody else wants to know Dan D blend you can just buy it on Amazon we don't have it in our store but you can buy it on Amazon.
The bag and it's like an instant coffee you just put it in a cup and add hot water and stir it up so it's very easy to use it's very easy to take with you different places if you're going to go meet somebody at a restaurant or a coffee shop you could just bring that with and ask for a cup of hot water and you can mix up your own and it's still participating things.
I know to counters when I go to find past zoom calls I can't find them it is it is the search emoji in the top of the members page right I've been gone for about a month now no so in the members page go to the zoom call page so in the members so I'm going there right now.
On the members site go to the zoom call page so there's different the members site is numerous pages one of the pages is zoom calls go to the zoom call page scroll down and you'll see all the past zoom calls so it'll say past zoom calls and they're all there seven years of past zoom calls every week I think I missed about six weeks.
six weeks all the seven years doing it they're all right there the only one that stands alone is when YouTube took our our zoom call platform down for a week we had to post one by itself you'll see that there too.
underneath the playlist we are actually producing dust it is producing our our old video platform because YouTube is picking off a video of ours at least one a week where they're saying it doesn't meet their criteria we fall into their medical misinformation.
spaking and they're deleting and one of our YouTube videos every week a number of months ago they demonetized their channel thinking that they're giving us a giant spaking by demonetizing our channel will our channel was never monetized I guess it was monetized we never made a pity on our channel so like we're highly viewed or anything like that but they thought that was going to be a big
slap well we can see they're writing on the wall they're going to take they're going to just take our entire channel down they're going against anybody that is speaking about the alternative cancer perspective at all so is Google basically we're getting fewer and fewer inquiries because Google is blocking all our Google ad words so it's difficult for somebody to find us this is not just us it's all the alternative doctors.
All the alternative cancer doctors. This is just the world that we live in we are just being.
It's just what it is so we had just and I talked about this month ago that we need to get our old video channel because YouTube's just going to take our channel now so it is up and it is running you can see it videos dot cutters clinic dot com we only have about half our videos out of there because we have so many videos that.
The people that we have put it on there it's taking some time to get all those videos on so it'll be our own channel that they can touch anymore it's hosted safely by a safe company that believes in health freedom so we will that's our it's our old page and we will have.
We will have all our YouTube videos up there too. The only issue right now is that the YouTube has that ability to create a paid playlist and the company that was is hope hosted our YouTube our new channel does not have that so they're creating that for us.
And so that's going to take some time to get that playlist up so hopefully YouTube will not.
Cancel us before we get all on that so it's videos dot cutters clinic dot com is the channel so all of our videos on our website then we'll actually be embedded from that all our videos on our blog will be embedded embedded from that instead of from YouTube.
Currently all our videos on our courses and all of our videos on our members site are embedded and held through HubSpot that's who hosts all our courses sites and our members site because we saw the right it on the wall with that as well.
When we when we created those sites we wanted to create it outside of Google's reach and outside of YouTube's reach and Facebook's reach because they are under the jurisdiction of the pharmaceutical industry and i'm not being cynical it's just the truth so but we need to get our own video platform.
Okay so thank you so i'm taking the SCAC T Tinsure do you have a preferred method of taking it yes so i'm.
How Renee Kessie who her last name is spelled backwards is SCAC who got the original formulation for the Ojibwe chief who used it up in Canada for cancer patients until the Canadian.
Communist government shut her down when she was actually giving it away had all had her clinic free of charge she was just totally doing it as a ministry helped hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of cancer patients until she was shut down.
She instructed to take the tea was to drink it like tea so you take the tables food and you put it in a cup and you had hot water just like you drink tea and then you sip it in the instruction as you sip it for about 15 to 30 minutes similar to how you drink tea.
And preferably on a fairly empty stomach you're drinking it with food you're eating you're drinking it on a fairly empty stomach now i know people that have you know the SCAC T Tinsure has come out with you know different companies use the same herbal formulation or something similar and it's in the capsule form.
And people have taken that and have sound well and gotten better but the original way to take it was as a tea that's why it was called SCAC T so putting it in a cup hot water sip it at a relatively empty stomach was the way that that her day who's a nurse was taught and that's how she taught others to take it.
Now we will have the link to our video channel up on our website and just so you know we will have the link to our video channel up on our member site and everything we just haven't put that up there yet because it's not completely done uploaded all the videos probably another week.
And then we have to get them all arranged I mean it's you can look at the videos of the same videos that are on YouTube for the most part now we're putting all our new shorts on there I think I think grace is still putting some on YouTube too but.
But we'll have it all arranged it take us another month or so and we'll get it completely orderly and and use it user friendly so.
All right any other questions there's a question the little red light above the words bulb power on the front of the generator that comes on and blinks when a program is ready isn't lit anymore the big tube lights up the tube lights up and flashes and we can hear the same noises but the little bulb isn't lit any longer.
Or it's really dim we can't really see it let even though it completely dark room can't really see it okay so those little bulbs are a little low voltage bulbs there's supposed to run for years but they do burn out sometimes they get they get bumped you know when you're moving the right around sometimes they can get banged for the bulb as you put the bulb back back to or something you can get bumped or they can just burn out so.
Yeah so after a period of time sometimes they don't work and i've had a machine where the on off switch when you turn it on it doesn't light up you know that's lit lights up red when you turn that that it doesn't light up but the machine is on it it's ready.
I think it's kind of a blessing when those lights go out because if I design that thing I wouldn't decide with any of those lights on there because they're annoying so.
As long as you have frequencies coming out of the bulb the hammer tube that you're using that's all that matters none of the other lights matter at all and again if I was the designer of it I wouldn't tell them even having on there so good questions though.
Another question come in I do want to address because somebody asked this question in the office today that they're getting the generator dull error so they're getting that error message that it can't communicate with the generator so they're trying to run a program it won't communicate with the generator.
Now even in version 6.4 which to rife has boasted that you'll get less and less of that now with the new 6.4 program we've had people have that same problem evil with the 6.4 the reason why sometimes when.
When you turn on your rife and it says can't communicate with the generator to have your generator plugged in you have to go through the troubleshooting well did it get unplugged at the USB you know cable come out from the port in the computer did it come out from the back of the rife machine those are your that should be your first thing that you look at.
If no that's all working it will give you that error can communicate with the generator if your rife isn't turned on so if your machine itself is turned off then it doesn't read that there's any generator there so it's going to give you that generator dull error there.
But people have troubleshooting no it's all plugged in it's all turned on everything's like that's not the issue when you're running your rife machine this is why we typically recommend when you hit run on your rife machine to close your computer when you close your computer you're putting your computer to sleep
because as soon as you hit run on the computer it sends the program to the generator it sends the program to the f1 17 or f1 22 you don't need the computer anymore once you hit run you could unplug the computer and you could burger to the other room it will still run the program the program has been sent to the generator run now I know a lot of people like to look at the program on the computer and look at the frequency that's running and look at the countdown of the time and all that kind of stuff.
Don't do that and the reason why I say don't do that is when you have the computer open you are actually exposing yourself to ef's because every computer produces you know ef's you don't need that.
Secondly you are exposing the computer to the frequencies from the rife machine you don't think these frequencies are strong they are strong and they can they can feed back to the computer and they can kind of mess up the program a little bit.
And so the countdown sometimes people have said the timer is going up it's not going down what the what the blazes is that well it's because the frequencies are just kind of messing with it it's still run the program but it can mess with the frequencies if you have a tendency to leave your computer open and run your program it can throw off the communication from the computer to the generator.
Not this time let's say it's running and it but next time the computer next time you hit try to run a program it doesn't read the generator because you threw off that connection so.
The solution of that is to number one just keep close your computer when you run a program so you don't have that because it puts the computer to sleep and the computer is now.
You know not being affected by the frequencies but if that does happen then you know just shut everything down turn your computer down reboot it and it should be just fun.
Worst case scenario you can lose the driver but that doesn't happen that often you'd have to download the driver from the website and we'd have to show you how to do that matter fact we do have instructions.
I don't know if we do I think we do have some instructions on the member site to do that but that should not be a problem it should not be something you have to do back to a question about the right and grounded if your feet are grounded you.
Once mentioned the right frequencies would not dissipate through out your body as well.
This was discussed primarily with the right grounding that as opposed to the earthy grounding that.
So the any grounding that is the same thing it's just a conductor of electricity back to your house ground so the idea that I've always said and I know Mike when Mike was with through if you always said oh you should use a grounding sheet and put the grounding sheet.
On your bed just do the whole full sheet on the bed but my argument was okay any frequencies that you have coming out of that bulb are going to be attracted to the ground okay they're going to be attracted to that ground and be carried basically out through that plan through the wire back to the breaker box back to the ground.
The grounding run that that's going to be its first desire electricity desires the easiest mode of transfer so that's going to be its first desire so if you're trying to treat kids are all night and you have the bulb right on your belly and you're sleeping on your back so let's pretend if you could see a picture of yourself in your mind you're laying on your back.
You're laying on your mattress your mattress has a grounding sheet on it and the bulb is right over your belly well the frequencies are going to go right through your body and it's going to go to the grounding band.
You're it's going to have a less of a chance for it to dissipate let's say if you have brain cancer it's going to have a less of a chance to dissipate up to your head because it'll be more attracted to the grody band now the truth be told you're going to still get lots of frequencies that are hitting your brain and your brain cancer.
So it wouldn't be too concerned about it but just to be safe I always said only use the grounding mattress cover the that you put under your mattress although lower half of your bed so it's like at your lower waist your buttocks and down.
Therefore because not everybody sleeps on their back all they love holding the bulb on their chest right you the bulb falls to your side you roll to your side for me by bulb is always on my side if my bulb was on my side basically laid right on the mattress and there was a grounding back right there I would lose a percentage of the frequencies right through the ground and they would have less of an impact on me.
Well if I have cancer or any disease and I want to be using a rife I want the frequencies to go through me and hit that site as much as possible.
Well I also wanted to be want to be grounded well yeah so personally I don't use a grounding mat when I'm sleeping.
At all summer long I know use a grounding mat at all and I did in the past have a grounding mat in the winter I used to have one of my chair at work that I sat on I don't anymore of course I get outside a lot yes in the winter I don't go outside barefoot so that's why I used a grounding mat on my chair during the winter time.
But in the summer I'm outside all the time and I'm barefoot all the time so I don't think I have any issue with you know too much positively charged ions on my body in the summertime which are probably more of a problem and I would benefit from using either a mat on my bed.
Or like a grounding sheet on my bed but I'd use it on the lower half of my bed or a grounding sheet or a grounded pad on my chair so any one of those things are good but just do it on your bed just do it on the lower half of your bed.
Did you close the computer when using the ion pro wave to what's not going to be as important because you got the frequencies going through the water and they're farther away from it so I would not worry about that.
Our laptop you gave us with a rife doesn't work unless it is plugged in now yeah sorry those batteries on those little laptops burn out that's why we always tell people always leave it plugged in seems like the battery's not recharging anymore.
And quite honestly you get most of your EMS from the battery so you're much better off having the laptop plugged in all the time anyhow so it's safer for you you're getting less EMS when you don't have a battery in your laptop.
I know some people in their laptops they've actually taken the battery out of it this is years ago I don't even know if they'll work without the battery in it no but if your battery doesn't recharge the battery's not working it's not discharging at EMS so it's much better if it's just plugged in.
Is it okay to have it to plug it in each time waiting to die on us no we shouldn't plug it all the time so always have the plug never unplug your laptop.
How does the supplement immune aloevia help with cancer so aloevia immune is a great supplement for cancer because it comes from.
The it comes from the aloe plant.
That is pull it up here that is a and it's pulling out just the polysaccharide so so understand the polysaccharides that are there certain group of polysaccharides that are immune.
Modulators that really help bring balance to the immune system so the immune modulator is something that when your immune system is suppressed in the case of cancer it boosts up your immune system when your immune system is hyper expressed in the case of like an auto immune disease it can actually help bring down that immune system and bring it back into balance that's the beauty of an immune modulator.
Now the benefits that mushrooms have in that is is the component of the mushroom that's called polysaccharides and the different types of mushrooms have different chained polysaccharides so poly means many saccharides is sugar so don't think it's sugar like it's glucose but it's a polysaccharide it has a completely different expression on the body it doesn't break down into glucose.
So it's not going to affect your blood glucose doors are going to feed the cancer so a polysaccharide works on the immune response in your body but it is they found in research there's a certain chain polysaccharides it gets like 300 saccharide molecules 300 to 500 saccharide molecules that have the best expression on immune stimulation.
Now different mushrooms work differently because they have different polysaccharides in them so the turkey tail tends to be better for for certain cancers and Rishi is different for different cancers and my talk is different for different cancers.
That's why I like from a mushroom standpoint is to use a blend now turkey tail has been found to be much more beneficial for breast cancer that's why we'll tend to use turkey tail for breast cancer.
But there's polysaccharides in more things than mushrooms the aloe plant has a lot of polysaccharides in it.
And this company aloevia has patented away to separate out the polysaccharides between I think it's 300 to 500 size polysaccharides and that's all that's in the immune product.
So it's taking three aloevia immune a day is like taking 12 to 18 just standard mushroom capsules a day because you're getting very specific immune modulating immune stimulating properties in the aloevia immune.
Aloevia immune is a powerful cancer killer you are spoken about it a lot because that is the product that I used for my cancer along with black sand blood root and number of other things I did take mushrooms as well to get a full balance of different polysaccharides to.
But we have a lot of people the aloevia immune product it's a great product so the benefit of the immune aloevia immune is the polysaccharide size so it's the size of polysaccharides the number of polysaccharides in that polysaccharide chain that makes it unique.
And that fraction of polysaccharide is a patented form of separation so there's I think they share it with one other company that has rights to use it but otherwise you won't find it any any other way any other place so the other questions all right.
Well thank you guys for being on and if you have anything in between calls make sure you get your questions into the member site and know that we're praying for you and we're just praying everybody has a great holiday season here with your families and you can stay focused on that.
And remember the reason for the season all right love you all by now.